of course we are following that breaking  news here this morning up in the  northeast part of the valley at lamb in  las vegas boulevard lamb  currently closed north of colton up to  alexander and las vegas boulevard closed  here at this intersection for this  investigation a live look the  investigation is happening down in this  intersection this is a look at las vegas  boulevard you can see it is closed  several metro vehicles in the area one  person did die there was a  fatal auto pedestrian crash and that  driver has been taken into custody the  suspected driver there and the vehicle  found at a nearby apartment complex but  if you do live up in the northeast part  of the valley there might be some  increased traffic in the area because of  these closures so just keep that in mind  as you head out the door john i'll send  it over to you